okay so this talk is about Quantum
proofs of deletion for learning with
errors
so a recent exciting idea in Quantum
cryptography is this notion of certified
deletion so suppose we have Alice and
Bob and Alice wants to send an encrypted
message to Bob let's imagine that this
encrypted message is a quantum
ciphertext
and what certified deletion allows Alice
to do is to request that Bob deletes the
ciphertext in which case he will produce
a classical certificate Pi that he can
send to Alice and Alice can verify the
certificate
and what certified deletion security
says is that if Alice is convinced that
the certificate is correct
then the plain text remains hidden even
if the secret key is now revealed okay
so clearly this is something that's
completely impossible to do in classical
cryptography and this notion was
introduced by Broadband in Islam who
gave a private key encryption schema
certified deletion that's inspired by
kind of the standard qkd protocol so we
have bb-84 States we have Randomness
extraction and also there's a classical
one-time pet
and later hiroka morimain ishimaki and
yamakawa extended the broadbandan Islam
scheme and gave a public key encryption
scheme as well as an attribute-based
encryption scheme where certified
deletion
and both of these prior Works
essentially rely on the same method
which I guess you can call the hybrid
approach so there's a Quantum part and
there's a classical part and the quantum
part is typically a random bb-84 state
and the classical part is typically a
classical ciphertext that encrypts some
information about this bb-84 States as
well as the data that's supposed to be
deleted
and then if you measure the quantum part
the bb84 state in a certain basis
sensitive information is deleted and
this information is kind of required to
decrypt and to recover the plain text
and one thing that's kind of been open
for a while is this the idea of
homomorphic encryption with certified
deletion so it's the same setting as
before except that you may also want the
server to maybe compute on encrypted
data but also maintain the certified
deletion property okay another thing is
this idea of public verification so the
idea is that in principle anyone should
be able to verify a deletion certificate
publicly and hiroka at all were able to
get public verification for public
encryption schemes under some strong
assumptions
but in this work I will show how to
construct a general template where you
get public verification for free and
this General template is specifically
tailored towards encryption schemes that
are built under lwe okay the learning
with errors assumption
and as an application of this General
template I will construct a homomorphic
encryption scheme with certified
deletion and public verification
and I want to stress that this work is
kind of the first work on certified
deletion that doesn't follow the hybrid
method and so there is no Quantum and
classical part there's only a single
Quantum State okay so before I get into
the general template and the tools we're
going to use I just want to give a brief
kind of background on the cryptographic
assumptions that we will use throughout
this talk
okay so I want to start with the
learning with errors assumptions so this
was introduced by regf in o5
and learning with errors is kind of our
or the most popular uh post Quantum
crypto assumption uh for example it's
being used for public key encryption and
it's currently
um you know part of the nist competition
and just a popular variant for post
Quantum cryptography but actually we can
do a lot more than just public key
encryption using lwe we can do things
that we don't really know how to get
under any other cryptographic
assumptions for example fully
homomorphic encryption or a classical
verification of quantum computations
and the learning with errors problem is
very easy to describe it's basically the
problem of distinguishing between two
samples and the first sample consists of
a random Matrix a
and a vector that's of the form s times
a plus e so here s is a random vector
and e is a gaussian vector so it's
sampled from a discrete gaussian
distribution of some standard deviation
Alpha Q
and the second sample is just a random
Matrix a and a completely random sample
u in other words the learning with
errors assumption says that you cannot
notice whether the sample is secretly
structured and of the form s times a
plus e or it's completely random
and lwe is actually a kind of average
case variant of a lattice problem known
as boundary distance decoding
okay I know a very related problem is
called the short integer solution this
is due to I type from 96. and sis is
kind of a very basic
um cryptographic hardness assumption
that's related to lattices and we can do
a lot of interesting things under the
sis assumption for example we get post
Quantum one-way functions that are
Collision resistant we get we get this
notion of a trapdoor we can use it for
signatures it has lots of applications
and the sis problem is basically the
following I give you a matrix a which is
chosen at random then I want to ask you
to find a short solution in the kernel
of a and here short means that the say
L2 Norm is less than some some value
beta which I choose as as a problem
parameter
okay and sis is a kind of average case
lattice problem and it's related to the
SVP problem the shortest Vector problem
and here the underlying lattice is the
lattice that consists of vectors in the
kernel of a and here you have to find a
short Vector in this lattice
okay using these two cryptographic
assumptions we can now discuss kind of
the general template that I want to use
for certified deletion
okay and the main building block is
something called a gaussian
superposition okay so we're going to
prepare
say as a warm up the following Quantum
State it's a Quantum superposition of
vectors X that have a gaussian
distribution
and in a second register we're going to
compute a times x
so in other words we're applying the
itai hash function coherently in a
second register and here a is say a
random Matrix in the integer smart q and
it's a wide Matrix
okay and if we measure the second
register we'll get some outcome which we
can call Y and something interesting
happens because the first register
collapses to a superposition of gaussian
weighted vectors that satisfy the
condition a times x equals y in other
words we now have a superposition of
short solutions to the inhomogeneous
version of the sis problem
and geometrically one way you can
describe these vectors is to say that
they lie in a coset or in a shift of the
perp lattice that I described earlier
where the purple lattice consists of all
vectors in a kernel of a
okay so we have this Quantum state so
how does this uh
uh or how can we use the state for the
purpose of certified deletion well it
turns out that this state is actually
the Fourier transform of another
gaussian state that will be useful for
our purposes
and so here this nice mathematical
property that we're going to exploit is
that these two states are related with
the Fourier transform
okay so on the left hand side we have a
gaussian state which I call the Primal
State and the Primal state is just a
superposition of random lwe samples
okay so geometrically you can imagine
that this is kind of a superposition of
lattice points that are shifted by some
gaussian ball okay and there's also a
complex phase which depends on why
and as I described before if you take
the Fourier transform of the state you
will get the gaussian coset state that I
talked about on the previous slide
and so the gaussian cosets say it is
again a superposition of short kind of
inhomogeneous sis Solutions
okay so now the template that we're
going to use for certified deletion is
maybe already apparent so what are we
going to do well we have two bases that
we can operate in so on the left hand
side we have the computational basis so
here we have you know random lwe samples
and we know what to do with them we can
use them to encrypt messages for example
and in the other basis the four-year
basis we have short Isis Solutions so
this is actually the basis we're going
to use to prove deletion and the other
bases the Primal domain we'll use to
encode data okay and to encrypt messages
and
Quantum information tells us that the
computational basis and the four-year
basis are sort of incompatible right you
can't measure in both of these bases
simultaneously so this is kind of the
high level idea why this scheme works
and uh let me just briefly explain how
you can turn the state on the left hand
side into a ciphertext okay and so here
we're going to use the Dual regev public
key encryption scheme
and so there's a public key and a secret
key the public key is just a random
Matrix a and we're going to sample it
with a short trapped or vector T okay
and T will be the secret key there will
be required to decrypt
and now if you want to encrypt a bit B
you can just output a Quantum ciphertext
that's precisely this gaussian
superposition of lwe samples from the
previous slide but we're going to shift
it by us by a vector that depends on the
bit okay this is exactly as in the
classical dual reggae scheme
and then we also have a phase which
depends on why and a and Y will
precisely be the verification key that
we will publicly broadcast so that
people can verify deletion certificates
okay so let's look at this in detail so
how would we delete a ciphertext so to
delete the ciphertext we just applied a
Fourier transform
and what what will happen is that these
uh ciphertext will get mapped into a
superposition of Isis Solutions with a
gaussian distribution and now the
crucial thing is that the plain text bit
b gets kicked into the phase of the
state okay so if you were to measure the
state now in the computational basis
the phase would be destroyed but you
would recover a short Isis solution Pi
that satisfies a times pi equals y okay
so obviously if you measure in a
computational basis the phase will be
destroyed but you now have a classical
certificate that you can use to prove
deletion okay so notice that a and Y are
public right I can just hand these uh
objects out to anybody and they could
immediately verify Isis solutions by
just checking if Pi is short and if it
maps to Y okay so public verification is
something we get for free using this
template so that's really nice
and we know that the Isis solution is
computationally or the Isis problem is
computationally intractable okay so
given the description of a and Y it's
computationally difficult to find such
Solutions but you know the adversary
gets a Quantum state from which they can
obtain such a solution so the adversary
clearly has a way of obtaining such
Solutions and they can
honestly follow the the protocol and
find those Solutions and we want to
argue that the only way the adversary
could get such Solutions is by
essentially measuring the state thereby
destroying the information in the phase
okay so before I talk about security
um let me briefly talk about
how we can get homomorphic encryption
so the answer is very simple we're going
to use a very similar scheme which is
also of the Dual reggae form and this is
inspired by the so-called dual GSW
scheme okay and this is a variant of
dual right GIF that allows you to get
homomorphic encryption
and it's aware of a very very similar
form except rather than vectors We Now
operate over matrices and we have this
Matrix G which is sort of a gadget
Matrix that is required for homomorphic
operations okay but uh deletion and
verification is very similar it's
exactly as before
okay so what can we do with this scheme
well it turns out that this scheme
allows a Quantum server to actually
compute unencrypted data but we also
have the certified deletion feature
right because we know that if we Fourier
transform and measure we get Isis
solutions that we can show to the
verifier
and in my paper I describe how you can
actually do both in the same protocol
you can actually compute and encrypt the
data and afterwards prove deletion
and uh there are some subtleties here
that I explained in the paper you need
one additional round of communication
and a rewinding step but in principle
you can do both in the same protocol
okay let me finally talk about security
so as a kind of basic security
ingredient we're going to use the
following property I call gaussian
collapsing okay this is a new property
that I introduce and it's uh essentially
a property of the itihash function
and gaussian collapsing says the
following
I either give you a superposition of
gaussian solutions such that a times x
equals y or I measure the state and I
give you a single solution x0 that
satisfies a times x 0 equals y where x0
is gaussian
then you cannot distinguish which state
I gave you okay so the two are
computationally indistinguishable and I
proved this under the assumption that
lwe is hard and a nice consequence of
this gaussian collapsing property is
that if you believe that the states at
the top are indistinguishable their
Fourier transforms are also
indistinguishable and this allows us to
argue basic kind of semantic security or
CPA security of our scheme because you
know we use superpositions of lwe
samples to encrypt and we shift them by
a bit and we know that under lwe the
state is indistinguishable from a
uniform superposition with a phase okay
so that's really nice and I want to
point out that gaussian collapsing is
kind of a special case of the collapsing
property that was introduced by unru
and it's uh kind of weaker in in two
ways so we only consider gaussian uh
superpositions rather than General
inputs to the hash function
and the second thing is that it has this
targeted flavor meaning that the
Challenger actually creates the state uh
himself
and we'll send the state to you and the
hash Y is also generated by the
Challenger rather than the adversary
okay so this is also a different uh
compared to the standard collapsing
property
okay so what about certified deletion
security so this is something you know a
little bit stronger than what I just
talked about we need something stronger
than CPA security so how do we get this
so first let's observe that gaussian
collapsing tells us that if we have the
ciphertext in the foyer basis
then we can just measure the state and
the adversary won't notice okay so
gaussian collapsing says you cannot
distinguish measured from non-measured
therefore I can just measure the state
to get a single pre-image it's
independent of B the adversary cannot
notice okay so this is what gaussian
collapsing says
but remember that for certified deletion
we want something stronger we want the
statement that if the adversary proves
to us that they have a valid certificate
then the data should remain hidden even
if the secret key is revealed okay so
how we could how could we possibly prove
such a statement so
I guess one could translate it into
another version of collapsing that's of
the following form so I call this strong
gaussian collapsing property and the
experiment is something like this I have
an adversary a and I either give it a
superposition of gaussian pre-images or
a single measured gaussian pre-image so
one of the two
and in the second step of the experiment
the adversary will actually reply with a
certificate and show us a pre-image that
satisfies a times pi equals y okay and
we check whether it is valid
and then we want to say that
now even if a trapdoor is given to the
adversary it's already too late okay
because if they had the trapped or at
the beginning of the experiment they
could easily tell whether they received
a superposition or a single measured
pre-image by just applying the Fourier
transform and distinguishing lwe from
uniform using the trapdoor but in our
experiment we first asked the adversary
to show us a pre-image and then if we're
convinced that it's correct we can
reveal a trapdoor and in some sense the
adversary cannot go back and tell
whether it initially received a
superposition or a single measured
pre-image okay so in other words we want
to claim that the only way a can obtain
a certificate Pi is by measuring the
state in the computational basis okay
and we know that if the adversary does
this then B is hidden once and for all
because it was in the phase and it's
erased okay now unfortunately unlike the
standard gaussian collapse in property
which I can prove under lwe the strong
gaussian collapsing property is much
more difficult to prove I made some
progress towards it in the paper and I
describe some general bottlenecks
but assuming this conjecture we get
public key encryption schemes and
homomorphic encryption schemes with
certified deletion and public
verification using a very simple
template so one open problem is to
actually prove this conjecture using
similar assumptions like LW or sis
okay so this brings me to the end of my
talk so I just want to highlight a quick
summary of the contributions so I
presented the first non-hi non-hybrid
approach for certified deletion schemes
that uses kind of quantum superpositions
of lwe samples and a nice side effect as
I mentioned is that you get public
verification for free okay and in
previous work this was only possible
with very strong cryptographic
assumptions
and the second contribution is this idea
of gaussian collapsing which is kind of
a natural
um
notion of the itai hash function
especially in the context when working
with lwe and SAS
and then I gave two public encryption
schemes for certified deletion the Dual
reggae scheme and the Dual GSW scheme
that's actually homomorphic okay so I
want to end with two open problems so
one is to actually prove the strong
gaussian collapsing property under LW in
sis or the inhomogeneous sis version and
in the paper I made some progress
towards this and I explained kind of the
last bottlenecks and that one would have
to solve
and the second open problem is to
actually dequantize the communication
between a client and a server in the fhe
protocol with certified deletion okay so
almost everything is classical for
example we can classically verify
deletion certificates and so on but
it'll be nice if one could de-quantize
the remaining communication so that the
client and the quantum server can
interact using classical channels only
okay so this marks the end of my talk uh
I'm happy to receive questions by email
and I'm looking forward to the
conference thank you for your attention